to this point what I've said is could be
imputed to be just talk about a superb
psychedelic drug and so they're saying
oh well so this guy advocates the use of
a superb psychedelic drug seems
reasonable or unreasonable depending on
where you went to church but it's not
that paradigm challenging but what is
paradigm challenging is the content of
the experience the content of the
experience is completely a mind-boggling
completely befuddled I don't know what
we're going to do with the content of
the experience because fully gotten out
and fully discussed and fully realized
it's not going to leave one brick upon
another in the cheerfully naive edifice
that our half-baked civilization has
erected this universal truth we're not
going to it's not science is not going
to be able to survive the encounter with
the psychedelic experience because it is
not an encounter with the Freudian you
know the repressed memories of your
miserable and battered childhood or
whatever it is you went through and it
isn't even an encounter with the
miserable memories of the battered
childhood of the human species that we
all went through a lot Carl you know
what that is all there but that's in the
hallway where you hang your hat and the
antechamber where they take your coat
the main event
folks doesn't even have anything to do
with the psychology of human beings the
main event is another dimension a
dimension so bizarre so titanically
peculiar so strange so unanticipated by
our language our history our literature
that it is literally like the discovery
of another world and and and there's
life in that world now a funny thing
about discovering new worlds is that you
usually when you get the new world all
mapped out you usually discover that
there's somebody living there and for
them it's not the new world at all and
you know you haven't discovered anything
you've just shown up in the middle of
their scene with a distorted rap sort of
like Christopher Columbus
you
the first thing that happened is that
there is a sense as though all the air
in the room had been sucked out all the
colors brighten this is that increase in
visual acuity all edges become sharp
distant things stand out in their
clarity this is at one toke at the two
toks you close your eyes you feel a
sense of anesthesia seeping through your
body you close your eyes and you see a
floral pattern rotating in space usually
yellow orange people who do this
occasionally and nobody does it a lot
call it the chrysanthemum it's a floral
pattern like a pattern in a Chinese
brocade this forms and stabilizes and
then you either break through it or you
require one more toke so you take let us
assume a third toke long and slow
through a glass pipe you vaporize this
stuff and you take it in and in and in
and there is definitely somewhere in
here a threshold a threshold which you
must exceed and when you do that this
membrane-like thing this chrysanthemum
will actually part and there is a sound
like the crumpling of a plastic bread
wrapper or the crackling of flame a
friend of mine says this is the radio
intellect of your soul exiting through
the anterior fontanelle at the top of
your head
could be in any case this crackling
sound and a tone a tone a
and then there's this impression of
transition and you're now 20 seconds
deep into this experience there's an
impression of transition there it's as
though there were a series of tunnels or
chambers that you are tumbling down
being propelled by some kind of muscle
behind you that is pushing you I mean
yes Earth Canal yes yes of course but
anyway as tunnel and what I've noticed
about this tunnel is the walls and
ceiling blocks and come down to meet
each other and where they touch they
pull apart with a and then you're
propelled into the next space and then
the next and then you are there where is
there it's Underground
how you know this you cannot say but
there is an irreconcilable sense of
enormous mass surrounding you in other
words you are underground you're at the
center of a mountain or something and
you're in a room which aficionados call
the dome and people will ask each other
did you see the dome were you there and
the the walls if such they'd be are
crawling with geometric hallucinations
very brightly colored very iridescent
with deep Sheen's and very high
reflective surfaces everything is
machine-like and polished and throbbing
with energy but that is not what
immediately arrests my attention
what arrests my attention is the fact
that this space is inhabited that the
immediate impression as you break into
it is there is a cheer you break in to
this space and are immediately swarmed
by squeaking self-transforming
elf machines these things which are made
of light and grammar and sound that come
chirping and squealing and tumbling
toward you and they say hooray welcome
you're here and my my immediate
impression no matter how many times I do
this and I've done it maybe 30 or 40
times which isn't a lot in a lifetime of
worshipping it my immediate impression
is that they are welcoming
welcome
because
with cold
and one of the strange things about DMT
is that it does not affect your mind in
the ordinary sense in that you know
drugs they make you giggle II they
frighten you they stimulate you they
depress you DMT does none of this you go
to that place with all your groceries
you're there and you're there thinking
Jesus age [ __ ] Christ what is this
what is it
and there it because and you're thinking
you know I must be dead
I've done it this time I must be dead
and so you you know you you think heart
heart yes mm heart pulse pulse
yes yes I mean while these things are
literally in your face and what they do
is they jump into your chest and then
they jump out again and what they're
doing and this is the point I think
what they're doing is they are singing
chanting speaking in some kind of
language that is very bizarre to hear
but what is far more important is that
you can see it they speak in a language
which you see and this is completely
confounding because syntax is not
something you ordinarily reach out and
touch and in this space that's what's
happening and so like Jules self
dribbling basketballs these things come
running forward and what they are doing
with this visible language that they
create is they're making gifts they're
making gifts for you and they will say
would you know how come no one walks epp
feet which condenses as something which
looks like a cross between a soft with
camel a Havana cigar a piece of abalone
and opal and Nucky and they offer it to
you and you're looking at this thing and
as you look at it it also transforms
changes speaks sings undergoes
metastasis undergoes metamorphosis and
these things are just accumulating and
each elf machine creature elbows others
aside says look at this look at this
take this choose me this state of
incredible frenzy goes on for about
three minutes and all the time the elves
are saying don't give way to wonder do
not abandon yourself to amazement
pay attention pay attention look at what
we're doing look at what we're doing and
then do it do it and it's this thing
where then everything stops and they
wait and you feel like a loop a torch a
spark lift in your belly that begins to
move up your esophagus and eventually
when it reaches your mouth your mouth
just flies open and this language like
stuff comes out acoustically it's
the Jinhua wai-kwok CD teaching in
cohabiting the big difficulty team what
you're not hearing the startled friends
who sent you to this place they're
putting up with this what you're
experiencing is a visual modality where
these tones are surfaces shading colors
insects jewels you are making something
even jaywalk Harvey Logan Haig a food be
whoo-hoo yeah you know erase move
forward add cerulean put in sniffling
it's that sort of thing and and they go
mad with joy when you do this
so
this is an experience which in some form
I mean it will be different for each one
of you but in some form at least what
will be similar to my description is how
dramatic it will be it will hit you as
hard as it hit me if you do it right
this to me this experience is of a
fundamentally different order than any
other experience this side of the
yawning grave and why religions have not
been built around why empires have not
risen and fallen around the control of
its sources why theology has not
enshrined it as its central exhibit for
the presence of the other in the human
world I don't know I can tell the secret
as you notice nothing shuts me up but a
long long time ago I took an oath to
tell all secrets that came my way so how
can it be then
that a compound which each of us carries
right here right in the pineal gland
right in the Ozma chakra the
Philosopher's Stone is no further away
than that how can this be secret from us
how can we be trapped in a dimension of
such limitation and such mundaneness
when our own nervous systems and the
ecology around us and our own history
over the past half million years argues
that this is what we were born and bred
for this is where we belong this is what
at play in the fields of the goddess
must mean and somehow history has made
us dysfunctional buried the mystery made
it a at best a piece of secret knowledge
jealously guarded by somebody I mean I
don't know there are lots of mystery
cults and secret societies in the world
I don't know if any of them are guarding
DMT as a secret I may be so no one told
me to keep my mouth shut if this is not
the secret that these lineages are
guarding then they're guarding an empty
house this is the secret
the Western mind is very queasy around
these experiences that cast into doubt
its cherished delusions about how
reality is put together and when you get
to DMT you have hit the main vein I mean
I hold it in reserve as the ultimate
convince sir I mean that's for these
there are these people running around
you know who say Oh few people who are
into drugs
give me a good branch whiskey and a
little TV I think you're deluding
yourself say you do you well if you got
five minutes to invest in this
proposition my cheerful friend because
if you do have I got news for you